I welcome to CBS this morning I'm
Anthony Mason with Tony Duke opal Gayle
King is also Jericka Duncan is with us
welcome good to be here yeah I'm this
weekend we're the national weather map
looks like it's on fire a brutal heat
wave will scorch more than half of the
country this weekend a hundred ninety
five million people across 34 states are
now under heat alerts parts of the Upper
Midwest and areas along the East Coast
could see temperatures that feel like
110 degrees and even at night
temperatures in many cities may struggle
to drop below 80 degrees this means the
heat will increase at an even faster
pace the following morning Kris Van
Cleave is on New York's Rockaway Beach
Chris good morning how are conditions
out there where you are oh good morning
it's in the 70s here at the beach but we
have a breeze coming off the ocean
that's helping that's for now it's going
to get much hotter as the day goes on
New York City is going to feel like a
hundred and two today around a hundred
and ten this weekend it's going to be
that nasty swampy humid hot weather that
normally drives people to places like
the beach to cool off but officials are
warning people here even to be careful
to watch the amount of time they spend
in the Sun and those excessive heat
warnings aren't just New York City it's
Philadelphia it's Washington DC here in
the New York area over the weekend there
was supposed to be the annual triathlon
well that has been canceled because of
the extreme heat three thousand athletes
will receive a full refund race
officials say they were simply unable to
provide a safe event experience in
upstate New York the Saratoga racetrack
has cancelled all of Saturday's races
because of the heat and something to
think about if you're coming to the
beach not only do you need to wear
sunscreen and watch the amount of time
you spend in the Sun you need to watch
your feet because the sand is going to
get dangerously hot it heats up a lot
faster than the water it can actually
cause serious burns to your feet and
even here at the beach it's gonna feel
like it's about a hundred degrees Chris
thank you well this year is expected to
be one of the warmest years ever
recorded the government agency NOAA says
the month of June set a global record as
the hottest in 140 years
chief weather caster Lonnie Quinn of our
New York
Station wcbs-tv is here Lonnie is there
any relief in sight from this heatwave
yeah really not until Monday or Tuesday
for some folks this is gonna be
throughout the entire weekend now the
culprit at least one of them is the jet
stream okay it's so far north now
typically there would be like a ridge of
big troughs somebody would get some cool
air
it's basically flowing from west to east
and here's the deal with a high-pressure
right now around the Tennessee Valley
that high-pressure with nothing to stop
and remember the jet stream is so far
north it just expands and expands and
expands it affects a lot of people let
me show you this the area that is under
some sort of a heat advisory being a
high heat warning or heat advisory
extends anywhere from well I'll tell you
this way extends anywhere from northern
Maine all the way to New Mexico
that's like 2,000 miles of advisories
and and what that means is as far as the
numbers look over here I want to show
you what we have as far as a heat index
what the air feels like on your skin you
have numbers for Friday feeling like a
hundred and thirteen in Des Moines feels
like a hundred and ten in Washington DC
you go into your day tomorrow
it's gonna feel even hotter for some
folks it'll be feeling like you know 110
around New York City for Saturday
actually Saturday feeling like 99 110 in
Washington DC
I feel like 106 for Louisville what heat
index means all right your body when it
gets hot it releases the heat by
sweating right and then the cooling
effect takes place when that sweat
evaporates but if it's so muggy that the
sweat can't evaporate so that's your
heat index that sweat just stays on
you're like under a sweater of heat
during some of the hottest air that we
have had so far this year Tony let's go
over to you while running out of color
on the red and the spectrum there yeah
if we'd be let's see some blues and
greens but not gonna happen all right
thank you very much